they write down strangled her to death
we've got nothing the killer found a way
to get Karla Castillo into his car and
he drove her to church filled that it's
not random it might be you may never
know and you may have to live with that
there's no time 13 o clock and it's
episode 97 97 counting down to that big
ol 100th episode yeah maybe I shouldn't
hype it up too much but I think it's
gonna be awesome though yeah we did a
lot of material for it last night we had
shot a battle with her over and her
husband Eric was over and we had a lot
of fun and we realized that she alcohol
was consumed yeah I discussed like my
recent breakup across and it's very sad
yeah we did actually record a lot of
material last night part I still have to
edit it and everything like that because
episode is actually gonna be out on July
17th yeah so I wanted to make sure that
I had a lot of material for it ahead of
time so I had time to like put it all
together and make it as cool as I could
make it yeah it's gonna be a kind of a
variety show we do a bunch of cases and
we were gonna do like 10 lists of tent
hangings yeah make a hundred they might
talk about we realized that man
seriously we did two lists and the show
is like three hours yeah 25 hours yeah
we're just gonna lead with it with the
visible 20 and bonus stuff I kind of got
lazy from all that you know alcohol I
was drinking I let I let Shauna battle
glitter take over the show for me so she
sat in for a while you guys are gonna
love it though because she's like
Larry's comments on my lying true crime
yeah yeah was super fun but yeah that's
what we said all they doing last night
that was Saturday night they're still
trying to recover from it yeah like I
said we drank a great deal but the
second I cool I drank a lot but it was
over like a 12 hour period right cuz
there's a long time yeah so it wasn't
like and we ate and stuff and you know I
had to cook Indian food he makes the
best Indian food you have we ever talked
about that before now I'm gonna cook
your you know he could make anything
pretty much I have no training so I know
what I'm doing but really eyes your
Indian food and your Thai food pretty
good or my favorite I know or your
Hungarian paprika thank you that is also
I just made I just pulled a Thai dish
you know just out of nowhere I inherited
a damn papaya a big huge papaya yeah
yeah and I had to use it something so I
decided to make it a chicken Thai
chicken papaya Kurtz we never made
before I ever made it before is really
good it did turn out very good a little
bit leftover I make it so we're now it
is Sunday evening and we're recording
episode 97 which is going to be another
true crime show today we are drinking
something a little unusual
where we sell a cow peas now what we do
about your hair of the dog is Sunday and
I just I like to have one drink like
before more doing the show just loosen
up you know yeah it's peanut butter
jelly vodka this is Van Gogh PB&J vodka
with cranberries cranberry juice nice is
for its it's funny because I worked for
Van Gogh vodka yeah and they you know I
was a graphic designer there years ago
when they were first launching the PB&J
flavor because they were trying to
compete with pinnacle yeah who was
having huge you know you like this
flavor but nobody liked this flavor but
I kind of feel like it's weird it's a
little acquired taste but you have to
know what to mix it with they didn't
know what to do with it if you mix it
with grape juice
is good if you mix it with cranberry
juice is good yeah the best thing you
can do with it mix it with caramel vodka
yeah and coke and put salt around the
result the red it tastes just like a
payday bar yeah it's good but see I
don't think they make the PB&J bite
anymore I think they just continued it
like in the back of the liquor store you
know other you know cherry and like your
regular ones you're all very good
they're all naturally flavored they're a
little more expensive that was the
problem it could not compete with their
artificially flavored tentacle it's
twice the price twice enterprise and the
article the artificially flavored
chemical vodka actually tastes better it
pretty is pretty damn depends on the
flavor yeah is she too you know very
effective the pinnacle whipped cream is
to die for
I do love that stock yeah but as far as
mango goes I mean I can drink that
espresso vodka like by itself no you
have to mix it with anything right
that's how good it is and the cherry
also but like I said I think a lot of
their flavor spent discontinued we all
got laid off like back in 2013 or
whatever it was but anyway alright so
we're we do kind of sell like out from
home and we make this schedule yes you
know sometimes it's like a Tuesday night
but we got it's rare that we have a
weekend off now so we just work at home
and have people show usually yeah I mean
we do go out still but I mean we used to
go out to two times a week yeah when you
and me first started going out we went
out almost every night yeah I don't know
how we could afford it
how does lose my liver still that's what
our tabs yeah so actually I drink a lot
less than yes now it's just like you
know maybe two or three nights a week
water cocktail you know like it's prior
to Friday night Saturday night or when
we're doing the show we'll have one or
two just to kind of loosen up you know
yeah yeah we encourage the audience to
go ahead and partake it's it's it's a
fun thing to do if applicable
alcohol is banned at some Arabic
countries so we can understand well face
the death penalty right and also if
you're like a Mormon or something they
can't drink again and a half coat of
caffeine oh my god I would die hmm what
would I do without coffee I don't know I
don't know seriously it's a yeah I mean
apostate yeah yeah so let's do some
shout outs yeah our latest movie review
if you haven't seen it we actually did
we went a little crazy and we did the
Daniel Craig James Bond film yeah
everybody we know is contact us man
watching this now that you guys are
talking about it now it sounds kind of
cool yeah Sean I wanted to see you'll
see you know that's what trainig lloyd
wanted to see him yeah that's what I
thought because I was like I you know
like I said on the show I've seen pretty
much all the James Bond movies over the
years but it wasn't really anything I
sought out I usually just ended up
watching him accidentally with it like
on cable or some [ __ ] but these ones are
actually really good and really well
made so yeah and there is a cult
references in the second one and there
yeah there is some gnosis in all four of
them a cult gnosis that's one of the
reasons why we did that or I really
ended that show it is relevant to our
show well but I'm gonna say that on the
next movie review I kind of want to
maybe do go back to like maybe old
sci-fi because I have like a huge list
of stuff I still got again yeah we can
do it we can see how that goes also if
you have checked out our Zazzle store
lately I put up four new shirt designs
new and improved shirt designs and I
think they're pretty [ __ ] cool if I
do say so they're I think they're a big
improvement over the old ones you know I
did an Atlanta Ripper 1i HH Holmes one
yeah
those through my favorite I really like
Atlanta Ripper yeah I'm actually not
really nice like I said you know I'm a
graphic designer by trade that's what I
went to school to do but I approach
things as very like laid-back a lot of
times I don't have a picture in my head
time not usually but I just kind of like
look at the blank page that I just kind
of [ __ ] around with stuff like [ __ ]
around with letters yeah [ __ ] around and
then like I end up something and I'm
like so it's like surprising I write
like that too
yeah bladder Ripper I really liked that
one it's got a picture of HH Holmes with
this hotel behind the murder castle yeah
we got a new demon child I got a new
demon so you're gonna like this one this
is a good one and I did a who put Bella
in the witch Elm with like a skull and
like a little tree I didn't see yeah so
yeah I got those four I tried to do more
we were talking about we wanted to do a
little more like some simpler kind of
designs I said I wanted something that
looked like an 80s misfits shirt or or a
cramped shirt where it was just kind of
like white art with like one color some
you wear the club yeah yeah so I want to
something like that and you wanted some
stuff that you could wear that was a
little more not masculine necessarily
but that was just more stark and more
straight a punk rockers yeah cuz I tend
to like doing more like complicated
designs you know I'm just into that kind
of baroque kind of love yeah I want more
simplistic masculine kind of punk rock
yeah kind of like a Joy Division album
cover we'll work on something like that
later it's called JD closer okay our
friends a story I don't use that fun oh
yeah that's like their font of that
would look good in like good day where
you know to be yeah put your black pants
on hear from you your dog morons on just
walk around that shirt it look cool yeah
exactly my red Doc Martens I also have
blue and green plaid Doc Martens I
forgot about I got those in the UK like
many many years ago back in the 90s and
they're still in good shape because
they're not Martin's also if you would
like to financially support the show you
can check out our patreon at patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
at wordpress.com and we would also like
to welcome our newest big-ticket patron
Jake
JK Thank You Man thanks man fantastic so
yeah that's Ted later that's pretty
awesome I know yeah we're getting up
there we're getting up there and patrons
getting up there and subs yeah we're the
little shows it could yeah if there was
only
some way where we can get delivered to
them or reasonably-priced shirts it'd be
nice to be I'm still kind of working on
that shirt yeah the shirts are really
expensive and the shipping is really
excited so I don't know I'm gonna try
and work that out work because I do want
like people to have shirts but you know
so being transform them into walking
billboards yeah these are cool shirts
there I can afford it oh and also be
sure to check out our 13 o'clock
subreddit which I think I've said on the
last couple shows our fan Duncan started
it and probably I think most all of the
episodes are up at this point so if
you're into Reddit and want to go talk
to other fans of the show then go and
check that out all right now let's go to
our news story since we're doing a
true-crime show today we're doing the
alphabet murders otherwise known as the
double initial killings I'm gonna mainly
kind of focus on the original like
unsolved ones because there are actually
two sets of these and they're not
entirely certain whether they were
related or not because it happened like
across the country and a couple years
apart so I'm kind of gonna get into that
but since it's true crime I always have
to do a Golden State killer update now
one thing that they've been doing since
they found this [ __ ] you know he
committed so many crimes in California
and he was so wide-ranging in the state
at the time the cops are pretty much
pulling out all the cold cases that they
have from that era and from those areas
that they have DNA evidence for and
compared it to the guy just in case you
know something else might come up so in
that vein they had actually been trying
to solve a murder of a woman and her
four-year-old son this is Rhonda wicks
she was 24 years old and her
four-year-old son's name was Donald they
were murdered in Cindy Valley in 1978
now the thing about this was that for
many many years her ex-boyfriend whose
name was Craig Koli he was in prison for
this murder for 38 years yeah you
talking about this now in 2016 I believe
they started having doubts about it
being him and after they did a DNA
comparison it's that they found out that
it wasn't him so he had spent all this
time in jail for a crime he didn't
commit
so they eventually ended up letting him
out I believe it was last year or about
a year and a half ago so they kind of
thought since this happened in Sydney
Valley since it happened around the same
time as the original Night Stalker kind
of as well let's roll the dice maybe
D'Angelo did this one too because it
obviously wasn't the boyfriend so there
was a big article about it and it's
funny because one of our fans sent me a
Facebook message about it and I think
they wrote the headline for maximum like
you know Golden State killer exonerated
I'm like what yeah yeah it wasn't
exonerated of any of the 12 that one it
was just this one and actually the
detectives on the case said we didn't
really think it was him but we thought
it was a long shot and we thought we had
the DNA we might as well you know it
could have been him it was certainly
possible he was in the area at the time
but it was not him so this murder of
this woman and her kid are still
unsolved because you know now that they
know that the ex-boyfriend didn't do it
who's now his entire life is Rob's been
spent in prison for something he didn't
do ridiculous yeah and it's probably no
legal recourse yeah it's like I'm sure
he'll get a gigantic settlement but it's
like what good yeah 38 years you would
think that I mean you'd have to get
millions of million dollars because they
would have to give you at least back pay
a lot of times I hear that like the
states have certain times certain types
of protection against that kind of [ __ ]
though where you can't sue them because
reasons that type of deal but we'll see
although I have heard and like I just
like you said it might depend on the
state but I have heard of some people
that have spent large chunks of their
life in prison and then they were
exonerated they usually get a very large
settlements like I said it would have to
because it would have to make up for all
those years of yours where you would at
least get some kind of a disability
where they cut you a check every month
you know yeah they need to take care of
38 years you're socially you know you
have a social handicap at that point
because you don't have a work history
years yeah no work history I was a
little kid when they go to prison it's
like the world is entirely different now
no no social skills no civilian social
skills for 30 years you can't get a job
no you know how are you a job he
probably doesn't even like hardly know
her you don't have any skills yeah
that's well you have any real life
skills and what are you gonna do you go
to employer says yeah I was wrongfully
imprisoned for 38 years they're gonna go
man it's terrible but
what next I can't really do anything for
you you don't eat ooh so I can see it
from their point of view also as much as
it sucks yeah so that's why I do think I
mean if they are sure that that guy
didn't do that I mean that dude that's
some compensatory you don't owe me 10
million dollars I need enough to like
dose the rest of their life okay because
big house is just I'm a kickback yeah
yeah just turn on joy at the time I had
left yeah that's exactly what you'd have
to do so I do feel bad for this guy but
you know once once he got let out they
said well maybe it's deep maybe it was
D'Angelo and maybe we can solve the case
but it wasn't him so this is still
unsolved that murder now the interesting
thing is they happen to mention this and
I don't know if they mentioned it
something else but remember how we were
wondering when we did the update on the
original Night Stalker murders we
weren't sure how they had gotten his DNA
exactly like what item exactly they they
had taken from him in the crime scene
yeah and actually what they did was the
first thing they did was he they
followed him because he was under
surveillance they followed him to a
Hobby Lobby and he was in there buying
some [ __ ] and they took DNA from his car
door handle damn when he was in the
store they can get DNA off a car door
handle well yeah it was only like bodily
fluids now man they're gotten so good
they can just do with sweat yep damn and
then after that when when it came back a
match then they went through his garbage
yeah and got a tissue that he had blown
his nose on or wiped his name you can't
run from DNA not now nope they got that
down to a science like I said this
murder is still unsolved but it wasn't
D'Angelo and it wasn't that poor bastard
that was in jail for almost 40 years
yeah I feel for you dude if you're out
there yeah yeah that sucks a lot yes all
right so now let's get to the main topic
and today we're talking about the
alphabet murders and this is an
interesting case because there's so many
like weird tendrils to it like I said
the original series of alphabet murders
like they're probably better known as
the double initial killings
actually a series of three murders of
little girls aged 10 to 12 in Rochester
New York in the early 1970s the thing
that seemed to tie these three murders
together was that all three victims
their first and last names started with
the same letter and where their bodies
were found the city name also started
with the same letter as their names
which would seem to imply a serial
killer with a weird OCD kind of fetish
there is still a lot of you know I'll
kind of get into this later but you know
there's still a lot of controversy over
you know whether this was one killer
whether it was two killers you know
they're not entirely certain but the
weird thing about it is that years later
because this these happen from 1971 to
1973 years later from 1977 to about the
early 90s there were another four
murders of women with their first and
last name starting with the same letter
but it was in California but they caught
that guy okay but I don't know if the
same guy is responsible it's just
there's oh this is so weird it's just so
weird it's kind of well-known I guess
and then in the upstate New York kind of
area but it's not usually one that comes
up there's a couple documentaries about
it I saw there's a show called dark
minds I can't remember the name of the
guy that hosts it he's a crime writer
and he goat he went and interviewed all
the detectives who originally worked on
the case they're all retired now it was
a long time ago there's that and I think
there was one other documentary on it
but that was about it I didn't find like
a lot of other podcasts about her or
anything so maybe it's not as big ticket
case even though it's super super weird
so the first victim of this purported
serial killer her name was Carmen
Cologne this was November 16 1971 now
she had been sent on a errand by her
family she was going to a pharmacy to
pick up a prescription for her mom and
then she was also I think she was
supposed to drop off some food like at
her grandfather's house this is in
Rochester New York she was 10 years old
now she goes apparently she's in the
pharmacy and the prescription isn't
ready yet and now some people later on
that she was acting like she was in a
hurry you know what I mean because you
know after what happened to her happened
to her people were kind of thinking well
maybe someone was waiting for her like I
mean this was only like a block or two
away from her house it wasn't like super
far right but they think someone might
have been waiting for her like in a car
or something they're not super sharp so
evidently she goes in she you know they
say she's in a hurry so if she goes back
outside and then she disappears on the
same day at least 38 motorists who are
driving down the 490 as I believe the
name of the highway they see a
half-naked little girl running down the
shoulder of the road like just tearing
ass down the road and then there's a car
going in Reverse that's like trying to
catch up with her you know what I mean
she has like no pants on okay and she
was like screaming time she said now the
horrible thing is that no one stopped to
help her and they're not entirely sure
why you know police said later that the
people did come forward and said that
they had seen her but later they said
well when we were driving by we weren't
entirely sure what we were looking at
yeah but I've got a family dispute or
you know great so a mentally handicapped
girl it's shitty but you're not really
you know maybe you were like I don't
know what's going on that's their family
that's their business I'm not getting
involved but nobody stopped that was the
last time she was seen two days later
there are two little boys and they're
riding their bicycles near this town
called chili and they find her
half-naked body she has been raped and
manually strangled pretty violent
beating also her skull is fractured I
know it was the she's just been left in
a ditch and they know it was the same
one that was seen in the freeway there
they're assuming because like I said
they said it was a girl with no pants
she was found with no no all she had on
was a sweater they said she was a little
dark-haired girl about ten years old but
she was so yeah they find her in a ditch
now nobody thought I mean nobody thought
anything about the pattern at the time
but it would become important later that
her first and last name's Carmen cologne
started to see also the place where she
was found
chili also starts to the see now some
sources say churchville but that also
starts with a c2 but that's where her
body was dumped I think it was kind of
on the
but just not buying this that's what
I'll get to that okay okay
because there's still kind of
controversy okay so they did recover the
girls pants it looked like they had kind
of just been thrown out of a car window
like some distance away now the first
suspect that they kind of focused on
there were actually two suspects on the
one of the documentaries that I watched
where the guy was interviewing four of
the investigators that have worked on
the case now two of the main
investigators they were partners but
they said that each of us had a
different idea about who the main
suspect was one of the guys said well
there was this one guy they didn't name
him because he actually died later and
he was never charged her and thinks
there's like a legal thing so I don't
know what his name is but they said he
was like a kitchen worker now he had
been seen around the area where Carmen
disappeared around the time of she been
gone and then subsequently after she was
found he skipped town
they also found it interesting that the
kitchen where he worked his timecard had
not been machine stamps but he had
written in the time that the murder had
taken place and they thought that was
very suspicious right so the one
investigator thought maybe it's that guy
and they found out when they kind of
looked into his background that he had
kind of been suspected of it was either
sexual assault or something like that
like toward a 15 year old girl right so
they thought that was very fishy but
they couldn't find him like he took off
now the other person that they were
interested in and this is the other
investigator thought was the main
suspect was Carmen's uncle Miguel now
almost all sources say uncle one source
I saw said that she that he was actually
Carmen's mother's common-law husband but
I'm gonna go with uncle because that's
what pretty much everybody says that was
like her relation now an interesting
thing was that the car that had been
seen following Carmen going in Reverse
was a small gray car most people said
which is the same kind of car that
Miguel had Miguel also skipped town a
couple days after the murder when they
looked in his car they found one of
Carmen's dolls and some of her hair and
it looked like the car had been cleaned
the car was new but it looked like it a
baby shower right there whoa wait a
minute
okay so they thought he was a very
strong suspect too so but like I said
these two detectives were kind of like
this one guy I thought it was maybe the
kitchen worker this other guy I thought
it was Miguel the uncle but they had
both taken off and they couldn't locate
either one of them so that's kind of
where it stood they think that he took
off for Puerto Rico because that's where
he was originally from Carbon Cola and
her family was Puerto Rican so they
couldn't find him he disappeared into
the jungle or some [ __ ] like that
now as I said they were sort of
investigating this is just a standalone
crime but then in spring of 1973 there's
another little girl in the same area
roughly the same area her name is Wanda
waka wits and she is 11 years old little
redheaded girl with freckles and she was
supposed to go same kind of thing she
got sent on a little errand to go pick
up some groceries by her mom I've seen
like a reconstruction of where her house
was at the time where the store was it
was literally like a block of wood not
even a block it was like right there so
she goes and also disappears now they
actually found her either the same day
or the next day I mean these this was
not a case of a killer hiding these
bodies this was someone raping and
murdering girls and just dumping them
like on the side of a road so that they
would be found now the interesting thing
about this again she has her first and
last names start with the same initial W
the place where she was found
was called Webster she was found behind
a rest stop so at that point they
started making a connection between the
two because there were a lot of
similarities both girls had been raped
and strangled they were from the same
you know kind of neighborhood they both
came from kind of lower middle-class
sort of neighborhood both of them had
learning difficulties developmental
disorders behavioral issues things of
that nature both of them were Catholics
and they had both been kidnapped at the
same time of the afternoon going on
particular errands but there were a
couple of differences too now Carmen had
been found half-naked the beating and
strangulation have been quite violent
there were a lot of like cuts on her
face her skull was fractured she had
been strangled by hand
from the front Wanda was actually found
fully dressed although she had also been
raped she had been strangled but not by
hand she had been strangled with a
ligature probably a rope or belt from
behind so now they're kind of not sure I
mean obviously there seems like there's
a connection because of the names and
because of the similar victim profile
but the method of their murder is not
exactly the same so they're still
working on this case a few months later
and this is the fall of the same year as
November of 1973 and then there was a
third one and actually I'm gonna take a
break right now okay because it's like
right at the halfway point then I'll
talk about the third victim and then
we're going to talk about the other [ __ ]
that happened later I'm like in
California so yeah so we're gonna take a
break right now and we'll we'll be back
in just a few minutes okay everybody
Jenni's got some new shirt designs up
four of them really good ones to Atlanta
Ripper who put Bella in the wit out the
HH Holmes murder castle and of course
demon child cuz man said he could these
are updated designs I think they look
really cool Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making jetty
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high-quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put spotlight on ourselves and
you can put a spotlight on yourselves if
you go ahead and pick up on these shirts
today you guys are gonna love them links
in the description WWL comm at 13
o'clock yes ago check out our store at
wwl com / 13 o'clock we got these four
cool new t-shirt designs plus all our
old ones if you'd rather get one of the
old ones but these ones are awesome and
you should check them out they're also
available in women's cotton they look
really cute JD's got some so thank you
go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back so now it's November
1973 it's been probably only about six
months since Wanda waka wits has been
murdered and then there was another
little girl her name was Michelle my
Enza she was 11 years old or was about
to turn 11 and she was actually taken
what happened to her and this is this is
very sad her mom had actually been at
this shopping center the day before and
had lost her purse there so the
following day Michelle goes out to
search the shopping center for her mom's
purse and she can't find it now
apparently Michelle's uncle saw her the
shopping center like looking around and
said hey I'll give you a ride home and
she said no but that was the last time
she ever got seen she got taken by
somebody two days later she was found in
a town called Macedon starts with an N
just like her names man here we go okay
so she had also been raped she was found
fully clothed
just like Wanda was she had also been
strangled with a rope or a belt from the
back just like Wanda was another
similarity that was something different
than what happened with Carmen was that
the second and third victims had
actually been fed by their killer Wanda
had frozen custard in her stomach and
Michelle had a hamburger in her stomach
so and these were foods that were not at
their house and they hadn't purchased
them or anything like that so they're
kind of thinking that whoever picked
them up because it was obviously someone
had picked them up in a car who lured
them into a car forced them into a car
and kind of a ruse yeah that they
actually took them to get some food now
they're also thinking that they may have
either redressed them after they were
dead or allowed them or raped them and
then let them put their clothes back on
and then killed them right but this
little girl was also found dumped and
just like the other two victims she kind
of came from a lower middle-class
neighborhood she kind of had some
learning disabilities she was kind of
overweight got teased a lot she hung out
with like younger kids yeah
so like I said the victim profile of the
three of these girls is very similar now
there's not taking him by force he's
using some kind of a root that's what
they're thinking it
to the car yeah and maybe had some to do
the promises of food that's yeah and
maybe could be he's impersonating a
relative or something like that or
something up there right yeah person to
me somebody they know because I mean you
know I know every time a child gets
abducted you know their family would say
oh they would never get in the car with
a stranger and stuff like which I don't
think is always the case because I think
sometimes that if predators are good at
that kind of [ __ ] they can sometimes
talk their way into it or attending to
be friendly and for all you know they
approach the kid and show flash a badge
and tell them that they're an undercover
cop right you know they've been an
emergency and their parents you know
been hurt and that we got to go to have
a deal yeah and on the way that hey you
just get something to eat on the way
something like that well and they were
thinking too and I think some of the
investigators said this on the
documentary that the fact that the
killer fed these two girls
they're like that kind of makes them
think that he used that he lured them
into the car because he's kind of like
look he gets them into the car look I'm
your friend or I'm the friend to your
stop or something yeah and then he's
like I'll get you a burger and then he's
like what he has to go get him a burger
now because if he goes somewhere else
they're gonna be like hey what are you
doing I thought you're gonna give me a
hamburger so you know what so he's
trying to establish trust yeah the weird
thing is is that there's a risk as you
go through her stomach and you find out
what she ate you might be able to
identify where that exactly came from go
to that restaurant say do you remember
this girl who was she with well the
interesting thing was that in the case
of Michelle by Enza there actually was a
witness yeah that saw a girl that fit
her description sitting in a car at a
fast-food restaurant and she looked like
she was crying and somebody saw like a
guy coming out with a bag of food and it
was a beige car that's about all they
could remember and they actually did get
a police sketch from that right but it
didn't really get she was crying and she
didn't run which leads me to believe
that he had told her something that made
her yeah but it didn't scare her enough
to get her to run away I had to bend
something to do with something with
something happened to your mom and dad
back home that's some some [ __ ] like
this yeah because you know how they do
you know like there's people that like
abduct kids and they have all kind of
[ __ ] story and you know it's kids
will if you say that you're a cop if you
did say or
figure if you say I know your mom and
stuff like some kids are gonna fall for
that yeah you know they don't know right
some adults would fall for that bad
what's your name you know and she goes
you know Maria something or other [ __ ]
okay what's your mother's name and then
L said he knows her name the money goes
okay you're the one I'm looking for your
mom Hospital yeah gotta go get her
gonna be something like that now the
situation arises that because obviously
the second and third Wanda and Michelle
yeah that was the same perpetrator it
was almost exactly the same MO the first
one they're not entirely sure because
there were even though it was very
similar in a lot of ways it was kind of
different that one was way more violent
than the other two you know the fact
that they had been fed the fact that
they were found with their clothes on
things like that so most of the
detectives in the case kind of leaned
toward maybe Carmen having been killed
by her uncle Miguel because that seemed
like a more personal crime yeah and then
the second to being killed by someone
else like a serial killer right do you
know they're not sure but that's that's
mostly what the detectives are leaning
toward now there were a couple of other
suspects too there was this one guy who
was a firefighter and he kind of came
onto their radar because he was arrested
pretty much in the act of trying to rape
a fifteen year old girl like in a garage
now when they looked into his history
they found that he had worked in fire
stations very near the neighborhoods of
the three girls like at the times that
they were taken his name was James
termini I believe but when they actually
chased him and went after him he killed
himself however later on after they got
because they only got DNA from the Wanda
Wanda walk what's case they had semen
that was left in her underwear all right
so they actually exhumed him later on
and got some DNA from his femur and
compared it and it wasn't the same that
it wasn't him but that you know he did a
bunch of other bad [ __ ] right now
interestingly Miguel Cologne the uncle
he was gone for quite a while like he
ran off to Puerto Rico they think and he
went off in the jungle somewhere but he
did event
come back to New York and they were able
to I don't know it's like the
documentary says well he kind of turn
himself in but he didn't really do that
but the problem was what ended up
happening with him is that the cops came
to his house because there was like a
domestic dispute like she was fighting
with his wife and his brother-in-law and
he shot at them like he didn't kill them
right and then the cops came and he told
the cops to shoot him and they didn't so
he shot himself so he is also dead okay
so there's no way of knowing you know
whether he did it like I said most of
the detectives kind of lean toward
Miguel like their uncle being
responsible for the first one and then
the other two being the work of an
unknown serial killer it's not positive
but that's kind of what they're leaning
toward there was also the kid the
initial kitchen worker that they thought
of that one of the detectives that that
was his main suspect they actually ended
up tracking him down but by the time
they tracked him down he was also dead
and they figured that he that he hadn't
been in Rochester when the second and
third girls were killed so it probably
wasn't him at that stage the case went
cold like I said they just called them
the alphabet murders and like I said
they're not entirely sure if the fact of
the girls having the same first and last
name initials and being dumped in a town
with the same they're not certain if
that was just a weird coincidence to
tist achill to me right now some of the
detectives there's two points of view on
this like most of the detectives that
works on the case they're like look well
considering the fact that we don't think
all three of them are the same killer
these are two separate killers so now
we're just talking about two victims
he's like so I just think that
statistical like I don't know because
you'd have to establish like
mathematically how common is it for
people to have the same initial for
their fertility can't be that uncommon
these are Latin names though right no
just the first one the first one was
just the first one you know so not
entirely sure but then this other dis
documentary I saw they talked to an FBI
profiler and he said no I don't think it
was a coincidence like I think this was
some kind of thing that this guy had yet
and there was they actually talked to an
unnamed a serial killer who's now uh you
know he's like a Hannibal Lecter type of
thing where he helps out the police with
out cases
and in his opinion he's like those
letters meant something to this guy that
was it was like his thing but if that is
the case then this is a very then this
guy is knows these girls like no their
person has to know their first and last
names and he is deliberately going and
dumping them somewhere right that will
have the same letter yeah so that
implies some planning that maybe the
rest of the the rest of the aspects of
the Congress crime don't really
demonstrate now some people online
because people are going crazy with this
alphabet thing they're like some people
online have said do you know that the
the letters of the the girls names are C
W and M they're like that's actually the
third the 13th and the 23rd letter of
the alphabet you know which yes so
they're like maybe it's a T some like
weird numerical like I think something
like that but yeah I think that's but
the serial killer the unnamed sir a
killer that was on this documentary he
was all about that he's like look it's
three three three and he's like look if
I double that
then it's six 26:46 he's like maybe
that's that guy's birthday alright you
know maybe he's a cancer like so he was
kind of getting into it and he was uh
kind of I don't know if he was a
pedophile killer like this guy was but
he was a similar kind of serial killer
and if he was into that aspect of it
maybe this other dude was too maybe
there's no telling so but you know
they're not really sure about that but
then this weird [ __ ] happens okay yes so
salmon in California that one of the
murders was in 1977 when was the 1978
when was in 1993 and when was in 1994
all four of these women now they were
not girls these were in their 20s I
believed the oldest one was maybe 37 now
and think about it could all four of
these women their first and last name
started with same letter and as a matter
of fact one of the victims was named
Carmen Cologne just like the first
little girl in Rochester New York so
that's why people thought that was a
little strange the other victims of that
series were Carmen Cologne Pamela
Parsons rock scene roguish and Tracy
Tafoya now these were all like I said
these were older women you know mostly
in their 20s some links to prostitution
although some of their families have
denied that but they do think that some
of them are linked to prostitution now
they caught this guy his name is Joseph
naso they didn't actually catch him
until 2011 but this dude he's like the
original I can original nightstalker
type dude he sort of I was like old I
mean they didn't catch him flus in 70s
he's one of these old angry
[ __ ] now how they caught him
was he was actually on parole for
stealing women's underwear okay
like from and you got I mean he'd been
arrested for other things like prior to
that but he been arrested for theft he
was on parole his parole officer shows
up at his house for an unannounced visit
and he sees some [ __ ] in his house that
he's not supposed to have like guns and
ammunition and some various things and
so he's like okay well you're not really
supposed to have this [ __ ] and then one
of the cops notices the guy was a
photographer he notices all these
pictures of he did not not fetish
necessarily but it like kind of
cheesecake kind of photos and stuff and
he's like some of the women in these
photos looked dead oh so that was a
little suspicious so they arrested the
guy and he actually ended up going on
trial you know the more they searched
through his house dude has what the
prosecutors called a rape diary oh [ __ ]
and it sounds like it's just like this
book where he's basically talking about
women that he's raped women that he
wants to rape her he had three notebooks
full of rape fantasies about this girl
or this woman she was in her 20s that
used to live like in the same apartment
building as him and she didn't know till
later on like after she had already
moved away and forgotten about the dude
she called him crazy Joe she said we
didn't know he was just like this angry
weird [ __ ] we didn't like him
but she had since moved away with her
husband and you know they didn't they
had forgotten all about him and then
investigators call her and said you know
there's three notebooks full of [ __ ]
about this guy's talking about he wants
to rape and kill you well they wouldn't
tell her what it said in there though
and I was like yeah well I would don't
think I would want out of that either
now the women and the photographs did
they ever identify not that I know of
now what his excuse was yeah was that
he's like oh I'm a photographer and I've
ended this kind of like cheesecake photo
type of thing so these are all willing
women that posed this way like poses it
there
and stuff and they even had like his
ex-wife I think she testified at his
trial he represented himself okay I read
some of his testimony like at the trial
he really really sounds like a complete
and total ass he just sounds like an
arrogant yeah I use and like even when
he got because he did get convicted of
those four murders of Brooke so they
call him the alphabet killer now because
there's four women had all the same
thing going on with the letters and
there's actually a picture of him gonna
run later and I'll put it on the YouTube
video where he got convicted and he just
like flicked off the camera yeah like
like a Crabby he looks like a crabby
angry old man right yeah I mean he just
looks like a bastard now for a while
they thought okay now here's the creepy
thing
Joseph naso like I said he's killing all
these people in California but in his
little rape diaries and in all his
little notebooks he seems to be making
references to murders and rapes in other
areas okay some of them I think what
first tick police off was the thing
where he said something about Buffalo
it's Buffalo New York and then they
found out that this guy used to live in
Rochester New York now he had moved away
from Rochester by 1969 but he still had
family there and was went back and forth
there all the time now remind me what
was happening in Rochester this is for
the first three though girl girls the
little girls now here's the thing
they're like okay well the fact of these
four women that have the letter thing
yeah and these three little girls that
have the letter thing and he used to
live in Rochester explain the letter
thing once he got busted no no but like
I said he might have I think he raped
and murdered other women too that they
never pinned on him or that they never
identified because this is one of those
guys where he's probably been moving
around okay and killing people all over
the place and they don't know because
they haven't you know got him all
together they they haven't matched the
case out and what did you say he did for
a living he was a photographer zog
referred that was it does he differ a
little nervous well he you know he did
wedding photography and all kind of
other center because they said at his
trial he took normal photographs to
write like you know that's how he made
his money okay I didn't know if you're
just an amateur no no he was a
professional photographer yeah yeah he
did weddings in [ __ ] so there are a
bunch of cases that he he didn't put
anybody's name
in this notebook yes he would just say
like where it was like oh I raped this
girl like outside of whatever this town
name was so they're trying to match [ __ ]
up kills the girl he says he kills her
as he just seemed right he mostly just
says rape and the thing about I don't
know I think he did actually say a
couple of times or he said
euphemistically right and he had killed
them he'd say something like you know
give it to her or I'll do it to or
something like that it's like you know
what I mean so it could say either thing
and now his Excuse at trial was that oh
well these are all just fantasies I'm
into that kind of stuff and blah blah
Roger I didn't buy to get the death
penalty so he's yeah so he's actually in
prison now
but the problem is that you know now
they're like that can't be a coincidence
with the Rochester thing cuz he was from
there but you know what
they took his DNA not a match no not a
match damn and I'm like how weird is
that
and the weird thing too is that one of
the victims had the exact same name Wow
isn't that creepy
now they asked one of the investigators
on this documentary I saw they said well
what they're like two of them had the
same name how can that be
he's like yeah but I mean in the Puerto
Rican community Carmen cologne is a
fairly common name thousands of girls
names that it's like it could totally be
just a random like a weird coincidence
which it could be that's right you know
that's fine but you would think because
there's so there's so many similarities
yeah but the thing though I mean he also
raped and strangled these women but
these women were older you don't usually
see like a pedophilic sort of serial
killer that goes after ten 11 year old
girls and then goes up to like you know
regular like 20s women in their 20s and
30s it's not unheard of but it's very
very unusual yeah it is unusual even
yeah even a pedophile murderer is very
unusual yeah usually a pedophile that
has no will to kill a child they love
the child yeah it's just very rare that
they actually killed them yeah yeah I
mean it's the same thing as rapists
there's a lot of rapists they rarely
killed a woman mostly just rape them
they let him go although some of them
like original Nightstalker Golden State
killer he worked up to it yeah cuz all
that time he was just raping and they
decided I was gonna kill me I remember
reading that for every everyone rapist
who kills
woman we know those are serial killers
for every one of those there's like 500
just straight-up rapists like a serial
rapist they just believe that yeah that
they're doing that might be a
conservative estimate of rape and the
[ __ ] in India world it's just a
regular serial real because I mean so
many women are raped yeah it's not there
are a lot of rapists out there but yeah
but most rapists have multiple victims
yeah most rapists have multiple victims
most of those rapists are not actually
killing them yeah I don't go now it was
the interesting thing about the original
series of the little girls in Rochester
they were asking this
you know incarcerated serial killer
about why the girls were just dumped in
plain sight why they were dumped the way
they were his insight if you want to
call it that was he's like I don't think
that this killer hates these girls I
think he wanted the companionship I
think he only killed them because he had
to because it was a witness he's like he
dumped them where they would be found
because he didn't want to do them any
further harm he didn't want their bodies
to rot where is that's what he said and
I was just kind of like that makes sense
but it's like that is so [ __ ] creepy
man but that's what they think like you
know just getting on serial rapist I
remember a case back from the 90s where
this guy came into the windows raped her
and Bush she got him good though because
what she did was a shoot after after he
was done he sat there and wanted to talk
with her you know so she talked with him
and said she said when you gonna come
back yeah you gonna come back and he's
like wait you want to come back because
yeah come back what's your number can I
call you and he gave her her number it
he is he was so you know well he was so
arrogant
yeah well this girl likes me so she gave
she's like yeah hilarious in a twisted
way yeah he gave her a he gave her his
number and she goes okay thanks I'll
call you he goes he had called me she
was she went right to the cops because
there's yeah gave his name his number
it's like because it's cumbria time yeah
oh my god yeah that probably works on a
percentage of them yeah is that stupid
or that color yeah they're they're so
arrogant in that case did they actually
think she likes me
oh my magical Declan
he was young about forever correctly he
was like only like 20 to 23 so he was
just [ __ ] was unwise I mean you
just committed a [ __ ] Class A felony
you did you know you're all right you
know you gonna come back yeah
what's your number [ __ ] I hope you're
dead now but yeah so I wanted to mention
we're kind of getting to the to the end
of the show a little bit but I wanted to
mention that actually one of the bigger
suspects a bit you know the better known
suspects of this was the infamous Ken
Bianchi the hillside strangler or
actually one of the hillside Stranglers
because it was actually him and his
cousin going around doing this stupid
[ __ ] now he was also a kidnapper a
rapist a serial killer and going around
strangling women and he actually went
after a couple underage girls - now the
thing about him even though that mostly
happened in Los Angeles that [ __ ] was
from Rochester also okay everybody's
from Rochester I'm from here all the
serial killers are from Rochester
sorry Rochester yeah no I'm just saying
that this guy was also he was born in
Rochester New York
so obviously they were like Oh serial
killer he's gone after some underage
girls he was after underage ones and you
know was in their 20s and 30s so they're
like well we have to check him out - now
he I think he ended up killed he
murdered 12 women I think and then I
don't even think they know how many
rapes he did him and his stupid cousin
he actually did almost all of his crimes
in tandem with his dirtbag cousin Angelo
Buono
he committed a couple crimes on his own
but I don't think they were underage
girls it was mostly just him and the
other guy like kind of working together
but they very very recently did a DNA he
is in prison now they did a DNA trying
to match him to the murder of Wanda waka
[ __ ]
in 1973 from Rochester New York not a
bad match so what the [ __ ] [ __ ] did
this man like I am willing to concede
that probably the first girl Carmen
cologne the 10 year old yeah that was
probably her uncle okay
so the cops in the case seemed to think
it was probably her uncle like I said
the cases were similar but there was
enough differences to think that maybe
whoever killed her probably knew her it
seemed more small than the other two so
I think there's a possibility that
Carmen was killed by her uncle he's dead
now so they can't he could he killed
himself so that seems weird and it
seemed weird logoff so it seems kind of
likely that he was the one that did that
even though he's family are adamant that
no he would never do such a thing but
you know that's but the other two girls
who the [ __ ] did that and and the weird
thing with the letters it's like I know
it might be a coincidence somebody who
got away with it yeah like I said they
do have DNA on the case just in Wanda's
case it's totally dead by now probably
yeah and you know the crazy thing about
this case was that there were just so
many likely suspects and I get is it
just because there's so many like dirt
bags around it's like there's dirt bags
all around there at that time there must
have been because it's like they just
had they're like hey here's this rapist
over here and through your research and
you know through your research I'm sure
you've noticed I mean because I know you
have because you've mentioned it to me
at certain places in at certain times it
becomes a vortex of [ __ ] bags yeah it
might have might go on for about a
twenty year period in a town or in a
small city and then it goes away but if
you were driving that city today stay
like 30 years later or forty years later
the city's not really there in the form
that it used it was weird like synergy
and that like as the economy becomes
depressed it gets crappier and crappier
and crappier there's not much jobs
people are moving away it's trust to
become kind of post-apocalyptic and
there's a large transient a lot of trans
people who who have lost their job they
don't have much of a future they go nuts
or you know not really good dots but
they started falling into bad behavior
yeah drugs come in alcohol next thing
you know crime and then serial rapes
serial murder kind of like maggots
feeding on a dying corpse of a [ __ ]
time very good analogy yeah yeah
and then once once it gets to that stage
then then all of a sudden there's flight
from the area yeah I mean it's just
vanishes time even either the city
collapses or it becomes Regent refined
people pay and it's a whole new
population in Detroit in the late
eighties for what about eighteen months
you know and before I joined into the
army
Detroit existed at that time I see
photographs of it now and most of its
gone
yeah let's just not there it's just
horned out yeah it's gone which is weird
which is what that's happening on
smaller scales in other places yeah but
like I said that's kind of an I was
talking to somebody on YouTube about it
about this whole thing where I kind of
got fascinated with all these cases that
were revolving around London Ontario
you know 60s just because they were so
many I mean you know that guy read a
whole book about it called murder City
and it was just like murder after murder
after and it was more than one killer
wasn't just like one serial killer
killing all these people it was a bomb
each other it was like between six to
eight different killers like I said it's
it's a local synergy it's something I'm
gonna look it's like I said maggots feed
nothing yeah kind of got me interested
in this whole geographical it sounds
like it's something that happens in an
area that's dying
yeah economically and I think I might
have mentioned this a little bit when we
were doing when we were recording our
hundredth episode last night I
remembered that I said I don't know if
it's just because some states or some
city's keep better records so it's
easier to like pull records about
murders and bitters and stuff but it's
like what the hell is going on with
[ __ ] Iowa because I have found so so
many unsolved murders and a serial
killer can pop up anywhere David Craig
and pop up in a middle-class areas you
know like yeah like Michelangelo Tisch
or but when you talk about four or five
of them all in the same area that's
usually an area that's falling apart or
it's somewhere that like I think that
what happened with London Ontario was
that it was a fairly large city but it
had been somewhat isolated but just
recently it got a new highway it had
opened up to all this new traffic and
because it was equidistant between
Detroit and Toronto you were getting
like all these people driving through
suddenly they had never you know what I
mean so they think that might have been
a factor like the floodgates right three
some of the scum to run run around it
yeah you wouldn't necessarily have gone
there right but now it's like now it's
all opened up so now you're getting all
the [ __ ]
yeah yep [ __ ] has now gaining access to
writers I mean they think that might
have been a fact I mean you know me I'm
into this big I'm into the dead mall
thing you seriously love to dead there's
a bunch of good ones but yeah and that's
one of the things well that's one of the
things that one of the guys is big into
it you know it wasn't dan bell it was it
was one of the other guys he said that
later on malls started to make new rules
to where they did not want public
transportation connected to the ball
they wanted only private yeah because
they're like if you're too poor to
afford a car we don't want your honest
you won't be shopping and what you're in
and if you're in there you might be
intimidating the paving customers and
you and they'll start read they'll start
leaving so you would think that you know
like oh you boy they would want as much
as many people but not as possible no
that's not what they want they actually
and and if you look at some of the
richest surviving malls that all have
Cartier and Gucci like that one in Miami
like that one of my image so exactly
what I'm talking about
you'd be lucky to find that that things
hidden basically cuz you better know
where that find it but I guarantee you
use you walked in there wearing the
wrong kind of clothes and speaking the
wrong dialect of English it wouldn't be
long before they asked you that you're
yeah they would just be you can't afford
anything in there so it's like what are
you doing here yeah you can't afford
anything in there I mean they that mall
was designed for you to go in there and
spend $5,000 a visit minimum and that's
you know they're selling $70,000 watches
in there you know normal people aren't
supposed to be in there I can't imagine
a is any $70,000 I don't watch it yeah
oh yeah and it mostly foreigners I just
can't like why a ten dollar Timex will
tell you the time the same way jewelry
and I don't really I don't know maybe
rich people you look at is just people
then the people that are buying that
kind of crap the $70,000 is just nothing
to them if that was
then they wouldn't even buy it but
here's the thing if even if I well I
don't know cuz I've never been rich I've
always been like broke-ass but even if I
had seventy thousand even if I didn't
even notice that seventy thousand
dollars was gone
why on earth would you spend another
watch I don't know but I don't think
well like what you don't use it this
joke it's like I'd rather go on a
vacation or something I guess it gets to
the point to where you just so jaded
you're just so spoiled that and you have
so much money there's like yeah like
there's no difference between $70,000
and seventy dollars so yeah just zeros
yeah yes something like that crazy I'll
never understand that so I can
experiment with you how I'm going to
whether I would spend $70,000 yeah I
kind of feel like I wouldn't I'm too old
to change my ways then yeah we can I
said poor you know pretty much just look
at that kind of stuff and I'm going yeah
I think I was an idiot if I bought that
that's what I mean if you like look at
that douche douche bag yeah some of
these really exotic cars you got I mean
I could try bro those exotic cars I
could work on more of those I thought I
would know all the specs on those cars
the guys that pull up and then
Lamborghinis and Maseratis don't even
know what they're driving can't drive
those dudes couldn't even get laid
well yeah yeah they can't I bet they
show up there's just like a douche alert
yeah they're either some kind of a
foreigner that doesn't you know that you
don't want to know you know I mean he's
from Saudi Arabia and he's only gonna be
here for a week and he treats you as a
peasant or he's some kind of drug dealer
or is just some really old guy you know
I mean it's not I don't get it so just
like the Corvette I love Corvettes but
I'm almost I'm too young for a Corvette
you have to be like 70 or 60 to own
those new Corvettes it's like a little
man car put your gray hair and I'm like
man I'm not 50 yet I can't I have to
now the day the 25 year old Corvette
owner that was 1972 alright so yeah we
kind of got off topic
well anyway hope you enjoyed this latest
true crime installment remember if you
like the show to like share subscribe
and share with all your friends tell
everybody about our show if you think
they would dig it also if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock or go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you would like to give
a one-time donation you can do that too
if you would like be sure to check out
our Zazzle store at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock I just added four brand new
t-shirt designs also check out our
latest movie review which was the Daniel
Craig James Bond movies the last four of
them which was a fun review to do and
that will do it for episode 97 we'll see
you next time bye
[Music]
streets just been imagined you may have
a heart of gold
[Music]
they just to mean a thing if you don't
mind your P's and Q's and ABCs
[Music]
you
[Music]